Despite huge differences in morphology and
biological structures, all living organisms
do the same three basic things;
they get food, digest it, and excrete waste materials.
Living organisms require energy to live.
Some produce their own food, usually through
photosynthesis, we call these autotrophs,
but many organisms cannot make their own food.
We call these heterotrophs and they...eat.
Among heterotrophic single-celled eukaryotes,
food is taken into the cell in various methods
but once it’s there, it's wrapped by
a membrane
and forms something called a food vacuole.
Then the cell flushes digestive enzymes inside
the food vacuole to start the digestion.
Nutrients are taken into the cytoplasm and
the waste material left in the vacuole then
basically fuses with the outer
membrane of the cell and what's left in the
vacuole is discharged into the environment
In some cases, like inside this beautiful
single-celled Nassula ornata which feeds on
filamentous cyanobacteria, content of the
food vacuole reacts with the digestive enzymes
and changes color.
But that process takes time.
Because each vacuole formed at a different
time, they are in different stages of digestion
which gives this cell it’s colorful polka
dots.
But how do these heterotrophic organisms get their food?
Well, in spite of a remarkable
amount of diversity, a lot of microorganisms
use one of the same three strategies for getting
their food.
Some of this will be familiar to the macro world
some of it will not.
One of the less familiar is filter feeding
which allows larger organisms to consume suspended
food particles or much smaller organisms.
There are filter-feeders in the macro-world,
baleen whales come to mind.
But while a whale must swim through giant
clouds of small organisms, in the microcosmos,
your food can come to you.
Some filter feeders use hair-like structures called cilia to create a vortex that brings
other microorganisms or food particles to
the cell mouth.
These cilia are specialized for this task
and their beating creates a current that expediently
and beautifully directs every nearby thing
into the waiting mouth of the microorganism.
The cilia are often too small for us to see,
but you can see their effects.
Take a look at these Paramecia. They're consuming tiny, tiny bacteria.
and you can see their cilia causing small organisms to tumble across them.
You can also see all of their food vacuoles on the inside,
and if you look very carefully, you can see a new food vacuole forming,
getting filled up with those tiny, bacterial cells.
Some of the best and most obvious filter feeders
are rotifers, micro-animals that use cilia
to create swirling vortices around their mouth parts.
You can see how successful this feeding strategy
is by it’s belly full of algae cells.
Every time its mouth fills with more algea,
it contracts to swallow the food.
Now observe these single-celled organisms called stentors,
they are much bigger than most other microorganisms.
You can actually see them with the naked eye.
and they also use filter feeding to push all of their algal food into their cell mouths.
(Ominous music)
Our second feeding mechanism, maybe the most familiar,
and the most exciting is called raptorial feeding.
Raptorial feeders selectively capture prey
and hunt other organisms.
In this video you can see Dileptus hunting.
It paralyzes one organism with the touch of its trunk-like proboscis, and then it pulls that organism into itself
in a process called phagocytosis.
Many of these microorganisms are armed with
something called toxicysts.
These are little harpoon-like structures filled
with toxins and they are located on a particular
part of the cell which the microorganism uses for hunting.
These tiny harpoons are then fired when they come in contact with prey organisms
which then become immobilized.
This is Bursaria, it’s a single-celled organism
with a huge mouth, and things have not gone
well for the Paramecium that is now inside it.
The Paramecium dies immediately because of the toxicysts on the inside of the Bursaria,
so at least it was quick.
Now get ready for some truly gorgeous footage of a micro-animal’s day going south.
First Paradileptus immobilizes the rotifer with fired toxicysts and the animal is swallowed by
the single-celled organism as it swims away.
This is a Frontonia which is a close relative
of Paramecia, but lacks the filter-feeding
habits of its relatives and feeds predaciously
on large diatoms and filamentous cyanobacteria
such as Oscillatoria here.
Though, in this case, it turns out this Frontonia
bit off a little more than he could chew.
Another raptorial feeding style is called
histophagy.
Histophagous organisms such as these single-celled
Coleps attack injured but live animals or
other single-celled organisms, sucking off
hunks of tissue rather than consuming whole organisms.
When they attack an animal, they enter wounds and ingest tissue often attacking in groups
because their chemical sensing abilities attract many of them from a distance,
like microscopic vultures.
When a number of them gather in one place, it’s hard to avoid another macro-world analog...piranhas,
devouring everything soft in no time at all.
There is a huge variety of raptorial feeding,
this is just the beginning, but we wanted to
show you one more before we move on.
This is Vampyrella, an amoeba with a suitable
name.
It specializes in feeding on filamentous
algae.
First, it bores a hole through the algal cell
wall and then slurps out the gooey, nutritious cytoplasm
Our final feeding mechanism, for today at least,
is diffusion feeding,
in which the predator just sits in the same place, relying
on the prey to accidentally make contact.
This is a Heliozoa, it’s a single celled
amoeboid and because of its resemblance to
the sun due to the rays coming out of its
cell, it’s sometimes called the “sun animalcule”.
The rays are called axopodia. These are sometimes used in locomotion and, in this case, for hunting prey.
Axopodia, are cytoplasmic extensions, meaning
they’re a part of the cell membrane, even
though they look like they’re sticking out
of it.
Each one has a central supporting
rod of microtubules that gives it this rigid structure.
The axopodia are coated in organelles that
discharge toxins when touched, which impair
or even paralyze Heliozoa's prey.
After the organism is captured, those microtubules
are drawn back into the cell, thus retracting
the axopodia and allowing the cell to swallow
the unlucky organism, or prey is just engulfed
by extrusions from the cell called pseudopodia.
In this video, a rotifer has been captured
by a Heliozoa and it is slowly getting eaten by it.
Now this is something that happens fairly freuently,
but we did capture something unusal here.
While it was stuck to Heliozoa's axopodia, this rotifer actually lays its egg.
But neither egg nor the rotifer is going to escape this.
Surprisingly heartbreaking.
This is a Suctorian, it is a ciliate just
like Paramecium and Stentor.
These organisms have hair-like cilia during the early stage of their life, but as adults they
develop bundles of tentacles.
Just like in Heliozoa these tentacles are
supported by an internal cylinder of microtubules.
The tip of the tentacles have extrusomes;
these are special structures that attach to
and immobilize any other ciliates that touch them.
The tentacles eventually penetrate the cell
membrane of the prey, and then the contents
of the prey is sucked out through the tentacle.
In the clip, a suctorian has caught 4 individual
Vorticella with its tentacles and is slowly
sucking their cytoplasm.
It looks a little like the vorticella have
the suctorian surrounded, but in fact, they
are powerless to escape it.
It’s a dangerous world out there.
The complex chemicals created by organisms
to sustain their life necessarily are useful
to other organisms, as building blocks and as fuel.
And so predation evolved.
It’s beautiful, it’s constant, and it’s
brutal.
Thank you for watching and for coming on this journey with us
as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
If you want to see more from our Master of Microscopes, James,
check out Jam's Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us,
that, my friends, is what the "subscribe" button is for!